aliens in der nachbarschaft also
außerirdisches leben in unserem
sonnensystem damit rechnen astrobiologen
denn auch hier auf der erde haben sie
leben an lebensfeindlichen orten
gefunden jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction
auf den ersten blick wirkt es ein
bisschen bescheuert
astrobiologen suchen auf unserer erde
nach außerirdischem leben bei uns auf
der erde
das sind quatsch wobei die idee dahinter
ist ziemlich durchdacht können hier auf
der erde organismen unter bedingungen
wie zum beispiel auf dem mars existieren
dann könnte es auch dort leben geben
denn vor einigen milliarden jahren da
gab es um den roten planeten noch eine
dichte atmosphäre inzwischen ist sie von
sonnen wind weggeweht worden
der mars hat nämlich kein schützendes
magnetfeld aus dieser zeit könnten also
lebewesen auf der mars oberfläche oder
besser in höhlen und spalten überlebt
haben
so wird in der kristallhöhle in mexiko
das bild nach lebensfeindlichen
bedingungen gesucht die aber trotzdem
noch so leben ermöglichen können hier
organismen überleben dann gibt es eine
wahrscheinlichkeit für leben zum
beispiel auf dem mars das deutsche
zentrum für luft- und raumfahrt dlr hat
diese theorie überprüft sie haben in den
alpen und in der antarktis flechten
gesammelt und zusammen mit bakterien 34
tage lang maß bedingungen ausgesetzt das
heißt sie wurden eine atmosphäre die zu
95 prozent aus kohlendioxid zu vier
prozent aus stickstoff und spuren von
argon und sauerstoff besteht ausgesetzt
zudem wurde der druck auf den mars dimas
druck angepasst da sind nur 6 mio
das ist noch mal 50 mal weniger als auf
dem mount everest wo man schon kaum noch
ohne beatmungsgerät existieren kann
die temperaturen schwankten zwischen
minus 50 und plus 23 grad und das
sonnenlicht das auf dem mars durch die
dünne atmosphäre nur wenig gefiltert
wird wurde simuliert
das ergebnis war schon ziemlich
verblüffend denn unter diesen
lebensfeindlichen bedingungen überlebten
flechten und bakterien
mehr noch sie betreiben photosynthese
dass es wirklich eine kleine sensation
zwar ist der beweis damit erstmal nur
für 34 tage erbracht aber immerhin in
alaska erforscht die nasa methoden wie
leben zum beispiel auf dem jupitermond
europa erforscht werden kann sie wollen
erstmal nicht nach den alien selbst
sondern nach ihren spuren suchen im
wasser könnte es das methan sein dass
von den fremden lebensformen abgegeben
wird ist ja hier auf der erde auch so
dafür haben sie einen roboter entwickelt
der unter der eisoberfläche entlang
fährt und dort nachmittags sucht das vom
meeresboden aufsteigt 1
ein solcher rover könnte zum beispiel
auf europa nach leben unter der
eisoberfläche suche dort gibt es zwei
bis dreimal so viel wasser wie auf der
erde leben wäre dort absolut möglich
zwei dinge sprechen also dafür dass wir
vielleicht schon bald außerirdisches
leben in unserem sonnensystem finden
erstens finden wir hier auf der erde
unter extrem lebensfeindlichen
bedingungen lebensformen und zweitens
wissen wir immer besser wie und wo wir
es aufspüren können
wenn in unserem sonnensystem
außerirdisches leben gefunden würde dann
würde das ein umdenken bedeuten dass
aliens betrifft leben wäre dann keine
ausnahme mehr sondern für die bisher
knapp 2000 gefundenen exoplaneten die
regel
das weltall würde nur so vor lebewesen
wimmeln noch mehr infos zu aliens wir
kriegen werden jetzt aliens gefunden
rekord 715 exoplaneten aufgespürt die
links sind natürlich auch in der video
beschreibung und wenn er das video bis
hierhin gesehen habt lasst ein
kostenloses abo da und hier im blog gibt
es jetzt nochmal wissenschaft täglich
dafür eben da klicken und was meint ihr
gibt es viele oder eher weniger aliens
diskutiert es in den kommentaren
und das war es auch schon bis dann
bleibt dran